please  no no no  what's the joke what i don't get it  you shot that damn fool  oh yeah no i still don't get it hey man  ain't nothing again  this is funny man duke can't snitch now  man don't fake laugh huh that's not real  i could tell no i think it's really  funny no you don't  look at him sitting there all dead  he was 20 and now he's dead  ain't never gonna have a wife for kids  now man what are you doing  wife and kids that ain't funny  his mom and dad ain't never gonna see  him again  no no you're ruining it for me  okay well i guess i just don't get it  then it's just that you shot him  that's all that's the whole thing oh  okay so  oh the hell is wrong with you you don't  shoot a dude that's already dead that's  not funny  oh  yeah yeah i guess i just don't get it  you